[Musique]
le nouveau coronavirus à plusieurs bouc
émissaire parmi eux le milliardaire
américain bill gates
et oui pauvre bill gates il existe
d'abord cette rumeur selon laquelle le
réchauffement d'ailleurs de microsoft
aurait prédit la pandémie et l'avènement
de 65 millions de décès non bill gates
n'est pas un devin comme l'a souligné ma
collègue bouchra wathiq dans un article
publié par les décrypteurs cette
croyance aviez d'une simulation réalisée
en octobre 2019 par l'école de santé
publique de l'université john hopkins
lors de cet événement intitulé event 201
des experts ont pris part à un exercice
de modélisation d'une pandémie fictive
de coronavirus l'exercice était réalisée
en partenariat avec le forum économique
mondial et la fondation bill et melinda
gates bill gates lui n'était pas
directement impliqué dans la simulation
face à la popularité de la rumeur
l'université john hopkins a précisé ceci
dans un communiqué publié en janvier
dernier pour ce scénario nous avons
modélisé une pandémie de coronavirus
fictive mais nous avons explicitement
dit que ce n'était pas une prédiction
l'exercice servait à mettre en évidence
la préparation et les défis qui
surviendraient dans une pandémie très
sévère fin de citation
le virus de la pandémie fictive
d'octobre 2010 9 différé de plusieurs
façons du strass cov 2 qui frappe
présentement la planète dans la
simulation le corps d'un virus se fictif
émergeait d'une porcherie au brésil et
causé la mort de 65 millions de
personnes
l'université john hopkins souligne que
ça ne prédit d'aucune façon que la kobe
19h à 65 millions de victimes
autre rumeur qui circule sur le web à
propos de bill gates
il aurait créé un vaccin contre le
nouveau virus
alors c'est faux oui la fondation gates
et finance le développement de nouveaux
vaccins à travers le monde mais mais je
le rappelle aucun vaccin sur le corps
navires us sur le nouveau corner virus
n'est sur le point d'être prêt les
experts estiment qu'il faudra entre 12
et 18 mois avant qu'un vaccin pour le
strass kof xii ne soit disponible noter
là bien sûr bill gates et ses folles
rumeurs
vous trouverez de plus amples détails
dans l'article signé bouchra wathier qui
est disponible sur notre site web
rappel important continuer à communiquer
avec nous à travers notre courriel et
notre groupe facebook
salut
[Musique]